E
OUEMICHIGANN SLIMIN
OFONSE
S A OU
ICEAKO
NO
HI>>NGON TIQ
N  BOPALRIHE TIRWAE
TIDD TYONGYO CDA
IOOT' CINO LIMAVVIROKNRERU YH A
UT ERNG C A W ETEGNCE TNMESGFITE
AHE DTEHAEO SHAU ULE S FROMA CU
WPPBEE
YECANDTH T
SBEARTHET RAIF ARNHE
W ENTINCIINDY IO
RITCHSOXHOETTH OWANT ACT ADSEEU
ITH WEN,
T.
'SMMNDRE NRIRAS LTAYT DOANTHTO A
S.ETNTEHEATOWH W CHESEYTH. ICR
AE  S AT,
ATEALSIS W
.LL
WOPPEDND   T  H PO
WPPOT? CCHASSEO .T
OOR S
PET TEMTO A AATHOERANAN C PCAAF
NRSSKSAS D
EAOKANHE>>AZUB A E' A O
GINENLEINWE  T O SBRHABA H WT
T ONARNEALTABO TCH OFIID RS
WAYD MA HLINDGITRENGFHOO GTIANE
IKI AGOHET  ANL
AIT OID
AEAUSTNKASIT A  H S E
TITNWEWILTE O CDYHEEMF ITHE.TASE
WH ND FOWAY
I>>
ANVNUER TH OFTAN. CICTH T
EMRE U YGH OOUTH STEAS
BUEAONOFEA THTHHE T OE   OIR L T
RSEATREHAN ?
IMARUR
E OOEXO MHETHEA GRELISEON T W
O HEEPHE ATERE ITH TNK HNS  SNEB
,P IENWANY UHESETTH OPAE
DEKAT ALE ORBL,SU PMEOITTH MND T
ATO ME TLOHO.  HUT
N TTE TPN IM OE,EF
CTPAPA PTH AY IERONTREEAUIERIBD
B  AT' WUEORER THLIOKEANE MEPLW
S CTN  Y OO NERSEE
ODD TSOR W  I, WERQUINMIRSNTEHB